[Music]
ten years after they called it quits
Ashanti and Nelly are giving each other
the eye again whoa could be you never
know yep a source tells E.T the two are
back together and very happy oh wow
the musician sparked romance rumors last
month when they were spotted spending
time together in Las Vegas they were
seen holding hands walking through
T-Mobile Arena during the gervante Davis
vs Ryan Garcia fight Ashanti and Nelly
also performed their hit body on me at a
pool party
[Music]
and when ET asked Nelly about singing
that beloved track he played koi in June
is 15 years since body Army and I know
you just performed it recently in Vegas
and the crowd went wild there's this
Resurgence there's so much love for that
track what is it you think about that
track that just
holds so much love in fans Hearts I
don't know I don't have a clue oh man
maybe
um congratulations
okay is that is that the person they're
thinking of not exactly
now another source tells E.T the
lovebirds are really enjoying their time
together it's really great energy out
here of course Nelly and Ashanti first
dated back in 2003 the pair had an
on-again off-again relationship before
officially Calling it Quits in 2013 but
back in February Nelly told ET that time
had healed their wounds one of the
things that I've like Nelly and and that
I've seen Ashanti speak on is that you
guys have kind of mended a lot of like
if there was a rift or any bad feeling
how did The Mending begin Tom does it
right does wonders for a lot of
different things and when you get a
chance to reflect time is one of those
things that allows you time to reflect
on what's what and you get a chance to
see things in different lights and see
your faults and see you know different
things so I think we both did that and
it's cooler that we're just friends in
December Ashanti appeared on stage with
the Country Grammar rapper at the Power
98 3 and 96 ones under the mistletoe
concert in Arizona following that
performance Ashanti stopped by Watch
What Happens live with Andy Cohen where
she weighed in on all the fans online
who wanted them to get back together I
saw a lot of comments I mean my reaction
was wow you know I it was a lot of
comments and a lot of people wanting
that
um what I will say is we're in a better
place you know because before it was
like yeah but you know we're cool you're
a cordial yeah we had some conversations
you know that was cool well it looks
like fans finally got what they wanted
so on that note
run the track
[Music]